là bạn thỏng mà và những ngày quý năm, nhiều các nhà mới khác chăng kiên cố đã sân thấy thế cho những mãi nhà tạc bởi dụng nát trước đây,
mắc lại sẹp mạng mới và nhiều vui trong người sân.
Công với nhiều vui và nhà mới, cán vộ chính sĩ đồn biên phòng và vệ dụng và các quý chỉ quyền địa vương,
đã đến tham hỏi đậu biên cho tạng các vượt dụng sình hoạch hiện yêu.
Để có được những ngày ảm hôm nay, cán vộ chính sĩ biên phòng đã chực tiếp dụng tình bàn, suốt bà con sự nhà.
Đồng thời phở hợp quy đậu vồn sạ hội hả khó chợt lâu dùng sinh hoạch và kinh phy,
có văn xuất người tán sử ổn địa quốc sống.
Ngày sau khi mà chúng tôi nhớ nấm được chỗ trường phó nhà tạng nhà dụng nát,
trên địa bàn xá buông nước, khi cấp quý chỉ quy đồn biên phòng và vệ dụng đã đến nạnh hộ.
Bảo cao cấp trên, và ngày sau khi được cấp trên cho phép,
thì đơn vị đã quy đọc cán vộ chính sĩ.
Dụng nhân dần phó nhà tạng và xây dụng nhà mới ngang nhất.
Chông thời gian khoảng 1 tháng dưới thì đơn vị đã
dụng nhân dần xây dụng được mười 2 con nhà đảm bà.
Vá cứng, nềm cứng, khung cứng, mấy cứng,
và ngoài thi công theo và khí kế ra thì đơn vị còn phối hợp với cấp quý,
chính quyền địa phương xá buông nước.
Hô chợt bà con lát đến cả đá ngoa xây dụng nhà vị xin.